bang-bang
she has smile on her face it's lunch
money time and there's a new logo so
she's super hype we got it guys
after complaining whining annoying yeah
I'm never changing it I never want to
hear about the logo ever again
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right a beautiful intelligent
angel like plenum Aaron over here I
can't tell if you look like an angel an
artist with a smock on or maybe just a
doctor with scrubs okay all right
don't forget black fly is now sponsoring
lunch money get money get paid go use
their interest-bearing account you can
deposit crypto or digital dollars and
earn up to eight point six percent bpy
no-brainer I'm invested in the company
we use it I love it black Viacom slash
lunch money or go click the link in the
description what's going on now that
you're an official host of the show
co-hosts what's up I don't know anything
that's going on with the stocks outside
of what that idiot Dave Portnoy talks
about idiot that's going on the stocks
she likes him she's just saying idiot
for the for the ratings try drive
ratings and so stock market first of all
two crazy things are going on the first
thing is last night there's a guy who's
a trade advisor to the White House who
said that the trade deal with China is
over literally said it's over we're done
looter big deal stocks went then he said
wait a second you grossly took my words
out of context I never said that the
stock the trade deal isn't done it's
still going and then stocks went you
misunderstood me what I meant to say is
yeah that's literally what happened and
so the stock market was being real
volatile based on some random dudes
words whether he said the trade deal was
over or not hey people wake up
it doesn't matter over the long-term
short-term price movements it's simply
sentiment changing but I saw a thing on
Twitter yesterday that I thought was
really interesting between June and
November or else at the end of June and
November in election years the stock
market historically has exploded in
value
you know why loaded you know what
because the president in office wants to
stay in office what makes it more
compelling
how can he control the hole that's well
because they start to do all kinds of
things in order to drive economic
activity devalue currencies all that
kind of stuff right and so it was just a
really interesting analysis that shows
usually the last week in June pretty
weak and then start of July into
November you get a massive run in the
market this analysis went back I think
as far as like nineteen fifty again
doesn't mean is gonna happen now but
keep your eye out if history repeats we
should have a really strong stock market
going into the election but again we got
a global pandemic going on so anything's
up for grabs here you canva okay canva I
was by the way canva when it first
launched I was a power user I was one of
the first people to use canva and nobody
knows that maybe if I could have
invested then but I was making thirty
thousand dollars a year so I probably
couldn't have okay ready
canva has raised sixty million dollars
in a six billion dollar valuation canva
by the way is a site where you can go
design little cards and things and
presentations it's awesome so you helped
them build a six billion dollar company
you didn't get paid you're lucky you
didn't know me then I'd have been
yelling and screaming say he'd better
get some money in there but we how would
you have known that it was gonna explode
like this cuz you used it that's my new
investing strategy
anything that pl'anna uses early is it
hey tell them all the companies Rent the
Runway glossier Rafi's canva every
single one of these companies she's like
one of the first users of and then they
explode in value so new pomp investing
strategy is planta what are you what are
you playing with on your photos another
one what do you was struck elephant it's
like a cosmetics thing or like a
skincare oh okay so canva but can I just
tell you guys the
badass right the CEO is a woman
obviously and she's a she's a savage she
is from Australia sixty million dollar
investment is a six billion dollar
valuation do that math yo know she's
awesome
um but can I just tell you this humble
brag of the co-founder cliff when he
told Forbes he said we could have raised
two billion instead of 60 million but I
think it would have been a really stupid
thing to do so they raised sixty million
dollars at a six billion dollar
valuation I'm no mathematician but
that's 1% yeah right it's pretty it's
not bad yeah I give you 1% of my company
if you give me 60 million dollars not
bad at all all right what's going on
with the Amazon it was always launching
a two billion dollar fund to invest in
climate technologies and it'll be things
like it's gonna be a cross number of
industries including transportation
logistics and energy generation
manufacturing and food and agriculture I
think that's really interesting mainly
because do you remember when kleiner
perkins tried to they had that green
fund back in the 2000s and it completely
imploded
but now there's like a second wave and
companies have figured out how to do it
sustainably sustainably and profitably
and profitably which is sometimes the
same thing what I really like about this
is it's a venture capital fund this is
not philanthropy they are trying to make
money doing this and the mandates pretty
large like they food and agriculture and
a climate fund transportation logistics
like in a climate fund you can you can
definitely draw kind of a dotted line to
those things but it's not like just
saying hey we're gonna go invest in you
know specific climate change technology
so someone who obviously does this
really well is Elon Musk right do we
know the relationship between Jeff Bezos
and Elon Musk yeah they hate each other
oh really I don't think they hate each
other but they're definitely not as kind
of cool as they you think you would
they'd be like good friends Jason
Calacanis I think introduced him for the
first time nearly at his house yeah he
told me that so they like didn't hit it
off no they did but now they're
competing to go to space and even must
recently tweeted and said to break up
Amazon's monopoly yes I don't think that
they're cool after that tweet I forgot
about that but you know what I didn't
forgetting climate change is real you
know what I didn't forget about what
you know they just forget about the fact
that I'm now in the animation the reason
why I asked about do you think climate
change is real is there's compelling
arguments on both sides based on data do
you know who Dave column is or Bret
Weinstein they're both kind of like
they're both professors at universities
and Dave calms actually practice
explanation of the podcast
yeah his explanation of an argument as
to why climate change wouldn't be real
and again I'm not saying that I agree
with this but his argument basically is
if you do all of the studies the studies
are inconclusive that humans are
actually the cause of climate change
according to him and what he basically
says is you can't just say oh everything
we've tested doesn't show it so it must
be humans right but like he's got a very
interesting argument as to why I'm not
interested but you know what I am
interested in since COBIT the air in New
York City is crisp it's fresh it's like
Mountain Air Base what are you gonna
ever filter on your nostrils it used to
be polluted I used to be able to smell
like things from a mile away now you
walk outside you open the window and
you're like aha
it's only outside cuz inside smells like
cat poop in here I'm gonna go do a deep
dive today on climate change I'm gonna
go do some research and see I'm gonna
spend a couple hours maybe and learn as
much as I can I'll report back are you
gonna be quiet yeah I don't care
hey guys you guys want to see something
pretty cool I've been using my new
headphones that I found their old
headphones but now they look like new
they're from American Airlines and I
just sit over here on my computer just
going away and they're from American
Airlines y'all don't want to let me fly
well ha I got one of your heads I think
that I probably borrowed them I'm gonna
give them back at some point I think oh
my god I think I walked off the plane
and forgot that they were somebody like
the the planes and then I'm never gonna
get an American sponsorship all right
let's go what's going on with Harvard
nonsense kinda look like a pilot right
now
Harvard lost it Oh God oh no I clicked
on the NAD okay what's going on with her
oh man
Harvard being honored oh man I love when
a Harvard kid out Harvard's Harvard so
Harvard Law student sues the university
over tuition prices as classes remain on
but like this would happen
look if you're a university and you say
hey if you pay me X dollars and you're
gonna get this experience and you don't
deliver on that experience we should
keep the price the same of course you're
gonna get sued I have no clue who wins
but like this you this was like the
easiest call of all time of course
somebody's gonna sue and then they're
gonna go to court and the court will
decide whether that is legal not legal
what does they've actually suggested
that to mitigate the difficulties of
online learning that we rent office
space of students I just fell over all
disrespected and not unheard by the
administration and I think as I've
learned this year the way to get justice
in America is through the legal system
America so screwed I love America see
it's it's [ __ ] like that like can't do
that in other countries you can just do
it I'll sue the hell out of you yeah but
is that really what we want to encourage
I mean I guess yeah he's pursuing what
he thinks is the right thing and yeah I
guess it's great that there's a legal
system no yes no no what I would do I
would never go to Harvard Washington but
why would you ever go into debt it's
probably I bet you her law schools like
seventy thousand dollars a year BAM your
boy is on target it's being $65,000 875
to go to zoom to be on zoom to pay them
65 will you stop interrupting me you're
in me
Tootsie I got ideas classes it's not
something I want to do when she yells at
me guys I was gonna wire card why are
speaking of another fraud okay
wire cords former CEO Markus Braun
arrested after two billion dollar
scandal explodes what the hell is going
on here what is why our card first of
all so I don't think we've talked about
this yet why our cards a company in
Germany they basically
for a long time now with like over a
year short sellers have been yelling and
screaming about their accounting
practices the Financial Times did a big
investigation into him the German
regulators banned short selling against
the company for a while and it came out
last week that all of a sudden auditors
were saying wait a second where's the
two billion dollars so literally about
two billion dollars they couldn't find
and there was two banks in Asia that
supposedly were holding that money and
then also the banks came out and said we
don't even have a relationship with the
field I have accounts here and they were
like oh but there was a rogue employee
who that like falsified documents and so
on Friday the CEO stepped down
he's been the CEO for years literally
like 10 years I think or 15 years and
and on Monday night he turned himself in
to authorities he was arrested and now
the company is saying wait a second we
may not have misplaced the two billion
maybe the two billion never actually
existed duh like I mean it this is also
a part of the beauty s2y I think a lot
of people believe short sellers are a
good thing but I think Josh wolf is the
one who says like short sellers are
basically the investigators of the
public markets and so they sniff this
one out like short sellers knew a while
ago that hey there's accounting you know
stuff kind of weird here called it out
and I ended up it looks like being right
what is that quote what happens in the
dark will come out in the light yes
Lamar Odom after he opens actually
watching tactical he didn't overdose
well and technically I close it's his
grandmother who got it from the Bible so
it's not you don't go look with that did
you I just is gonna get real mad at me
for saying this but did you see them
trying to cancel Jesus speak another
Bible if any of you guys didn't see
there's a guy who literally was tweeting
saying that we should take down all the
statues of Jesus comment let us know
what you think
I think I'm serious okay what's going on
Virgin Galactic so we're drinking lactic
is trying to Hotel fi the space station
houston we have a problem
houston we have a problem go ahead did
you not tell me to go ahead go ahead
see how I'm turn this way you see I knew
it was coming so
basically NASA wants Virgin Galactic's
to coordinate private trips to the ISS
that includes building out an orbital
astronaut readiness program for
companies or organizations that want to
send their people to space so there we
go
what's his name lunch money's gonna be
the first customer we're gonna send her
to space that old [ __ ] ain't going to
space all right
he ain't you know I know if they can
send Bob from whatever organization to
space they can send Tom no no no but
this is also different where are they
trying to put the hotel into ISS well
they are trying to put ISS yeah I don't
think that that's gonna be a popular
thing
why virgin would basically act as a
space travel agency corning coordinating
resources logistics and travel plans for
customers can I just say that like I
feel like virgin talks a big talk
Richard Branson talks a big talk but
then we really dodged a rock I don't
think anything look I'm a fan right I
believe in Richard Branson I believe in
shamov I believe in Virgin Galactic but
I don't know if we're talking about
hotels yet we just literally had the
entire country stop and get glued to
their televisions their computers their
phones Twitter etc and watch us launch
the first two Americans from American
soil in almost a decade and now a week
later two weeks later we're talking
about yeah we're gonna buy the hotel up
there yeah by the way we probably will
at some point the king of marketing and
there's I don't know I'd give Virgin
Galactic a 15 to 20 percent chance to be
the one to do it right so you've got
SpaceX you've got blue boards you got
Virgin Galactic maybe you got NASA in
there like I would give I'll give it to
the PSA a 90% chance did you see that
yes a is know what's PSA it has a 90%
chance of going to space with PSA polina
Space Agency and did you just think of
that no yes
that was good just saying China just
threw up the last satellite to build
their own
equivalent of GPS because GPS is run by
America no no it's a communist satellite
system what they just put up the last
satellite and now they have a competitor
to GPS and they did because GPS is
American owned oh interesting just
saying all right ain't last words for
the people now that you're an official
co-host and got your logo up there yes
thank you guys for running the campaign
to get me on the animation and the
cartoon and now I'm part of the club
next thing you know I can just kind of
grub you out to just be me Joe we're
gonna talk about removing that cartoon
hey alright guys that's it lunch money
he's over for today
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right please pray for me as I deal with
polina for the rest of today we'll see
you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block five so go check them out
there's a link in the description that
you can click on I'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what you're a bigger fan
of block fire than you are of me block
wise my second favorite thing in the
world behind polina they've got 3
products they can give you a US dollar
loan you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but
eight point six percent it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks at
block by subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy playing in the comment
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends